you okay careful all right all right
what okay Hillary is in absolute agony
one Stones she's been waiting for a hip
replacement since the start of the
pandemic and was finally due to have won
two days ago but it was canceled because
of the doctor's strike lovely you're
obviously in agony how difficult is it
for you to manage day to day I'm
constantly in pain I can't sleep at
night so I have to have a chair next to
the bed I can't walk to the pillar box
to post a letter and I can't go shopping
I can't meet friends for lunch I can't
do my job I'm in pain
pain brings you frustration
three-day strike by Junior doctors will
bring huge disruption to NHS Services
they insist this action is needed to
make the government listen to their
demands 35
um it would be to restore our pay back
to Net Zero if it's too much to ask for
is too much for us to lose doctors have
seen a huge pay cut over the last 15
years we're not asking for all that
money back in one go we're being very
reasonable in saying that we're willing
to work with the government in creative
ways to get back to Net Zero the
government though says the doctors are
asking for too much it claims it is
prepared to negotiate but only if they
call off the strikes first we moved in
terms of the government's position in
line with the offer that was accepted by
the NHS staff Council and by trade
unions representing a number of other
health workers and made an offer in line
with that but unfortunately the junior
doctors have refused to move from their
demand for 35 percent uh they're still
insisting on an increase of 35
industrial action this year has already
forced the cancellation of half a
million appointments but it's not just
operations these strikes put pressure on
every part of the hospital we've been
seeing an increase in activity the
unprecedented actually over the last few
days and with the industrial action
that's happening this week as well we're
going to have a High attendance figures
which will lead to longer weights
Hillary has been told she will have her
operation in July but she's afraid it
might take longer unless this bitter
dispute is resolved oh she's Josh is Sky
News in Essex